this week I spent a few nights at the
Sydney capsule hotel I was in town for a
physics conference and I thought it
would set the mood nicely there are
about 16 pods in the room each with
their own storage locker
[Music]
my initial impression is that it's
really good but it's getting late then I
don't want to disturb the people around
me so to avoid this from becoming a
capsule hotel ASMR I'll talk to you
tomorrow open the pod bay doors hell
Hey so here's my review so far it's
definitely very futuristic
it has vibes of hibernating on a
spaceship on out on our way to a
destination somewhere and it's pretty
spacious actually there is a room to
move around if you consider this to be
room it's about one meter by two meters
it's pretty much like a backpackers
though when you take away all those
futuristic stuff it's kind of in between
a backpackers and a hotel you've got a
lot more privacy than a normal
backpackers and the price is about in
between the two of them as well maybe 50
or $60 a night it kind of feels a little
bit antisocial because you never really
see your neighbors and it kind of feels
like everyone just keeps to their own
pod probably on their phones or whatever
it's nice in that way but it can also
feel a little bit lonely in here having
said that everyone I've met so far has
been really friendly here and I think
it's because a lot of people are here
for the novel experience and they want
to try it out something that I do like
about being in this capsule is that it
makes the world feel small so it's a
real contrast between the bustling
streets of Sydney down below because
we're right in the center of the city
and being in your own little pod where
you're sort of removed from all of that
and I kind of like that feeling I feel
like it's almost easy to be creative
inside of the pod because it sort of
removes distractions and you're left
with just the white electronic style
walls and your own mind there are
definitely some downsides to it like the
pods themselves are actually really
quite flimsy they seem to be made out of
sort of plastic material and that means
that you can feel other people in their
pods sort of moving around or when they
get in and out and if you're really
sensitive to sort of disturbances that
night maybe you wouldn't get a very good
sleep
I found it okay but it's definitely you
can hear other people and whilst
everyone's been really respectful and
not made much noise it's definitely a
sense of not being totally isolated the
captions themselves don't make any noise
the inbuilt alarm wakes you up with
flashing lights which was a bit stifling
there is a TV - but it doesn't display
instructions in English and it was
pretty hard to use to be honest
[Music]